-Welcome back, everybody,
I'm here with Chance the Rapper.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And we're about to go head
to head in a new game called
"Peanut Butter and
'That's My Jam' Tic-Tac-Toe".
-♪ Peanut Butter
'That's My Jam' Tic-Tac-Toe ♪
-Now, this is just
like regular tic-tac-toe,
but with an added challenge.
Each square contains
a piece of bread coated
with peanut butter and jam.
Instead of drawing an "X"
or an "O",
you have to bounce
a ping pong ball
and get it to stick to
the top of the slice of bread.
It doesn't matter if another
ball has already landed
on the bread, whoever gets
three in a row first wins.
Chance, you ready for this?
-I think so.
I just realized that it's jam,
like "That's My Jam",
which premieres tomorrow!
-See how slick I am?
-That's sick, that's sick.
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
-I'm ready.
-All right, since you're
our guest, you can go first.
-Oh, really?
All the pressure's on.
All right, here we go.
Oh, that was too hard.
All right.
These are a different kind
of ping pong balls.
-Yeah, they've got extra bounce.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Laughs ]
-[ Laughs ]
-All right, where do I go here?
The center one?
-What is the --
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Oh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Now that counts, right,
that counts.
-Yeah, we both got
that middle one.
♪♪
-We can just quit now,
if you want.
-No, go ahead, I don't --
♪♪
Oh, my God, what's that?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-All right, I can still win,
I can still win.
-Oh, no! Oh, my God!
-Oh, it fell off!
-Hey, come on.
That's ridiculous.
-That -- It's gone, right?
It's gone.
-Guys, don't cheer that loud.
-Let's go. Here we go.
Oh, I was so close.
♪♪
-I don't know what happened me.
[ Cheers and applause ]
What!
The winner!
-Let's go!
-Man, that was awesome.
Chance the Rapper, everybody.
"The Voice" airs Mondays
at 8 P.M.,
Tuesdays at 9 P.M. on NBC.
We'll be right back
with Maude Apatow.
How did you know how to do that?
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪